things are opening up and i just feel
like you know we've all had a rough five
years
trump plus coven was such a one-two
punch right
i mean punching the dick right a punch
in the what
she's punching in the dick she said it
she's not she's not a serious journalist
like you
that's right i forgot how to do this
where i was all right so you know
i temporarily forgot where i was no
so uh you know we all deserve a breather
which we got after the election and so
forth and now things are getting better
we we
need to have some fun for a while but i
just i just want people
to understand that we have not moved one
inch
in solving the fundamental problem that
we had six months ago
which is that the people of the united
states hate each other
yeah and will not work with each other
this is the essential problem
there is some new polling well first of
all um
78 percent of republicans say biden
was not legitimately did not
legitimately win the election
that's just from april 10th 78 and
that's ridiculous
well of course it's ridiculous 45 think
the attacks at the capitol went too far
but had a point
um 51 percent say the party's leaders
did not go far enough
to support trump contention that he won
the election
uh back in december there was a survey i
read the biggest threat to america's way
of life
the results from americans eight percent
think
foreign biggest threat to our way of
life 17
natural disasters viruses obviously that
was on their minds
20 think economic forces 54 percent
biggest threat to america's way of life
other people
[Music]
you know yeah i'm saying take a breather
enjoy yourself but
the right wing is not self-deported they
are not
they're not close to being interested in
rebranding
and as far as january 6 and the attack
on the capital
the lesson they took from that was we
must never let that happen again and by
happen i mean democracy
yeah exactly and i it's
if your biggest idea your biggest
problem
is that there's too much democracy and
so too much voting we got to crack down
on that
too much speech and protest and we got
to crack down on that too much access to
information let's crack down on that
i mean what a punch in the gut and for a
party
the republican party that makes a
pornography of patriotism
and practically fellates the founding
fathers it is jarring and disorienting
to watch them attack america nowhere my
mind is tonight
[Applause]
for late but they haven't lost late the
founding fathers i think i lost them oh
my god
all my f's i think i lost all my
founding fathers i can't do that
that's exactly what they do but you know
but this is the party of donald john
trump
gone are the days of reagan gone are the
days of
hw ghana the days of w oh yeah this is
donald john trump's party yeah what does
it look like he's still but he's not
gone
right the the trumpism mentality is
there we saw it january
6 the only reason why there are
people trying to i guess say that oh it
happened because of this
is because they got caught is because
they found out it was wrong
but i'm going to say this and i'm i'm
i'm trying not to be a prognosticator of
doom i'm not going down the sex road
that you've gone
but trying not to be a prognosticator of
doom but i'm going to tell you something
2022 watch what happens
at the polls trumpism still is here no
that he's still here
i keep saying he's here but it's like
the shark
that went back out to sea but we need a
bigger boat
because we did not kill the shark it
just went back out
no it's going to come back yeah
republicans are still being rewarded for
doubling down on trumpism and he's still
going to run again
oh yeah that's okay if he's not in jail
he's not going to be in jail
you